so what was tip number one for these
kinds of questions really really
carefully fantastic let's have a go okay
the world cup cricket final attracted
86,000 people to the game but nine 4,500
tickets were sold before the match okay
so there's the question I'm going to
start to write down the important
information this is me beginning to do
tip number two it using words okay this
is question six I immediately get thrown
these numbers but I don't want to just
put down numbers I want to know what
they mean nobody's words to do that so
I'm gonna say 86,000 what is 86,000 it's
the number of number the number of what
what does it represent yet people people
okay atc 2000 represent people but 90
4500 also kind of represents civil
rights how many how many turned up very
good I ever I'm gonna try and pick a
word that captures that I think
attendees will do it right there were
people who were actually there as
opposed to people who got a ticket but
internal okay all right so what was that
other number 90 4500 and like you told
me before that's the number of okay I
haven't started answering the question
yet I'm just getting my head into the
right space on making sure I know what's
going on parte what fraction of the sold
tickets were used ok so Part A I
couldn't start launching into a fraction
right away but I want to use words to
indicate what my fraction is sold
tickets sold tickets
okay so this is what I'm working up sad
again 6606 so now that I have what I'm
actually working out how many combined
these two numbers so I want to give me a
suggestion you don't want to throw it
out there yeah Rachel do I have a shot
it's okay okay so hot on let's just
pause for a second about 86,000 right so
that was the number of people there so
that's how many tickets were used right
so I've got a 6,000 but that's not all
the tickets that got sold right so we
divide that by 90 4,500 does that make
sense yeah sold tickets are sold tickets
used tickets are all clicking so far
okay now that's the important working
I'm not going to do the canceling on
that number are they a huge number so we
reach my calculator right and i'm going
to insert that fraction in you can of
course use your fraction button or
division either one will do fine if you
use the fraction button that's up there
at the top left it should hand you a
fraction straight back I believe we're
getting one soon to over 1800 check out
you guys get into my top yeah of course
if you hit the up if you chose to hit
the division button instead it'll feed
you a decimal how do you change it from
a decimal to ratchet yeah good use that
SD button and it'll just give you that
straight away and go back and forth
easily pause there's an air time read
carefully look back at the question have
I answered the questions that will they
want it no yes
look carefully there's a couple of
things I need to look for number one do
they want a fracture or do they want a
percentage I want a fraction I've given
them a fraction okay they want the sold
tickets that we used is that is that the
saltiest of use yeah it is I think I
checks out I'm done full stop okay so i
can finish but i wanted to check back to
the question make sure i answer let's
move on to bed yes yes sir I mean I
could so I could I could have a
conclusion it says a fraction of you
tickets sorry fraction of soul tickets
that we use was this I kind of think
I've sort of done that already right so
the alternative would be if I just
started like that right and it's like
I've got numbers that just appear out of
nowhere there are two give me a great
idea to sentence okay but having said it
I think we're okay good question alright
next part let's read carefully puppy
what percentage correct to the nearest
whole number of the soul tickets were
not used ok so what purse Watford my
percentage were not used so can someone
give me suggestion what might I am but
I'm right here ooh quality before i get
to the numbers which are wheel what
might i right to indicate verbally what
I'm actually calculating hey ah still
doing the numbers there will be 86,000
by the way what am I saying before I
launch into my numbers what am I
actually calculating weather yes the
unused unused yes okay okay so I've got
unused tickets right yeah let's get to
the numbers now okay because you know
I'm going to work out something
completely different based on what I've
actually trying to look out like okay so
how many weren't used how many where
news it's some number a thousand based
on this is how many I solved right and
then this is how many got used so if i
take the difference that's all those
leftover tickets that are still sitting
around
haven't been actually used on make sense
now that's the number of tickets but I
want a percentage so what to wire / yeah
it's gonna be the whole set of tickets
again isn't it 90 4500 okay by the way
just as a quick day as we were going
through because he's a big numbers some
of us thought it was a t600 right the
fact that i wrote 86,000 up here is my
own corrective so that I make sure that
I've written down the correct numbers
here so don't end up with some problems
because i did a transcription error okay
yeah this part again this is Mitzvahed
for my calculator okay so i'm going to
reach in my calculator i'm gonna pop
that in this should be on the numerator
throw for 500
okay now once you put that in your
getting on site because I popped it into
my calculator you may have done
something different I put it in using
the fraction button it's handed me a
fraction back okay and there's no
problem with that that's not wrong does
it answer the question it doesn't does
it I actually want the question wants a
percentage okay so how am I gonna do
that good okay so I'm gonna go in
reverse so yeah I'm getting a decimal
kid I'm gonna write this decimal down
and you remember how I said approximate
at the end at the end so I'm not there
yet I'm gonna write this down what are
those dots indicate at the end there's
more good it keeps going ok so our Peter
would be like above these numbers but
these dots over here me there's actually
more just not writing everything this is
a decimal how do I go from a decimal to
a percentage what do I do ya anythin you
take away the decimal point okay so
let's just I'll come to that it and i'll
go to your suggestion and second foot i
need to do something to this decimal
point one thing you could do is you
could move it twice right because we
didn't just went somewhere it's not like
a 9000 / wah in my calculator there's a
way I can do so these are multiplied by
something if you want to give me a
suggestion it's gonna be a hundred right
because percent per set as in like
century right that means divided by a
hundred so you do this to undo that
right so in my calculator I've got that
number of rain in this way and i'm going
to multiply by 100 ether oops um yes
well because it's a closet turf it's a
fraction if you remember we looked at
terminating and recurring decimals yeah
and it's not a cert so eventually it's
going to repeat but it will repeat after
a very long time
you say 99 4708 995 because it's brown
opposite exactly right okay so but I
don't need to worry about any of that do
I cuz how far do I want to approximate
what do I actually want I want one I
want the nearest whole number right so
this is a this is 8.99 blah blah blah
per set so now here here I finally
reached the end do I need to do any more
calculations or just approximate i use
am a squiggly equal sign to indicate
approximately equals two to show you
that i'm doing the approximation and of
course of course 99 s gotta round up ok
when you approximate kind of like this
feebly equal signs is always useful to
indicate how much you're approximating
so that's nearest look at the question
again yeah you can I say what percent or
you can say whole number that's what be
a question actually says ok so you can
see how each of our tips in here was
really useful to communicate what was
going on are many people will just write
down this this question I can almost
guarantee would be too much you'd get
one even if it was perfectly right the
other one is for showing how you got
there